[Music]
foreign
of new footage has released via TV spot
to new trailers from the film so let's
just get straight into it and break down
this new footage so Peter makes a hero
land in his doc OCT greet him with hello
Peter Peter then says do I know you and
then we get a new voice line from Doc Ox
saying do you think your fancy new suit
will save you we then cut to a very cool
new shot of what looks like Peter
breaking out of a car or a bus using his
iron spider now I gotta say I really
like the animation of the iron spider
here it looks very spider-like and I
don't know it seems just very cool and
different to what we've usually seen
with this iron spider we then have
another new line from Doc Ock which he
says looks like we got competition now
what I'm wondering is is this referring
to Peter and his iron spider or is this
referring to Green Goblin because we
know sometimes you're in this sequence a
Green Goblin swoops into scene and joins
the fight so what I'm wondering is when
he says it looks like we're gonna
competition is he referring to Green
Goblin let me know what you guys think
but let's go continue the end of the new
footage of Dr Octopus here we have him
slamming Peter underneath the bridge to
then saying you're not Peter to which
Spider-Man responds with I am so
confused right now we have new footage
from a lecture which you can see playing
in the background here nothing too much
to break down here but I gotta say I'm
really loving his new design anyway
moving on to the next part of the
footage we have footage from Sandman
that we actually haven't had too much
footage from Sandman in this film so far
so it's good to get more footage and
what we have here in the first shot is
him reaching out which is quite
reminiscent of him from Spider-Man 3 and
then over to the next set of the footage
we have him actually grabbing and
crushing Peter here which looks like
this is also from the construction
battle which we saw at the end of the
official trailer now I think this battle
will probably take part towards the end
of the film yeah Peter this is happy one
of those guys huh one of the guys made a
mud what's going on call me back sir we
actually have some new footage from
happy here and to be honest he doesn't
seem too happy he seems quite confused
and worried about these new guys these
new villains which he doesn't know who
they are so he's trying to call Peter
here and ask about who these new guys
are do you know anything about it why
are they here can you stop them I was
reading online that people were thinking
happy is referring to other Spider-Man
here being like Oh who are these guys do
you know anything about that however
there's a line where he says it looks
like there's some guy made of mud
obviously that is referring to Sandman
which means she is referring to the
villains and not the other Spider-Man
now I was talking about Sandman and how
we haven't had too much new footage from
him well also that is the same case for
the lizard We have basically had no new
footage of him apart from a couple
second clip where he's at the bottom of
the screen in a fight sequence we've
finally got some new footage of the
lizard it's very short but it's just him
roaring which is pretty cool
was that a dinosaur got to say the
design looks great and you can also
notice he actually has four fingers on
his right hand compared to five on his
left in the next set of footage Peter is
saying um he needs some help and then
Ned comes in and says let's catch some
Multiverse men now one thing to note
here is that um Doctor Strange was doing
a spell so they everyone can forget that
it was Peter Parker yet Ned knows his
Spiderman so I'm wondering did Peter
tell them again or because the spell
failed does that mean everyone still
knows he is Spider-Man so in the
sequence where Peter Parker has grabbed
the cube and is under run from Doctor
Strange we have some new footage here
basically he's on the train however this
time around there are cities everywhere
so some crazy doctor strange stuff going
on there anyway that's pretty much it
for the new footage that we've got from
TV spots on trailers I'm sure there'll
be many new TV spots coming in the
coming days up to the film's release so
if you want more videos covering the
footage like this one please let me know
in the comment section below and also
let me know what do you think of this
new footage are you guys excited for the
new film let me know and also to show
your support please like subscribe and
turn notifications on thanks for
watching guys